okay I'm a fix-it guy I can't just leave
this laying here it's too heavy
so let me give you a couple of things to
think about okay number one the intent
of the student law student loan law that
put in this through this ridiculous
process by which people can get hundreds
of thousands of dollars in debt for
education the intent and it's a noble
intent but it had an unintended
consequence because as always with
government programs you get idiots
involved and so the intent was to create
a well educated productive creative
society that's what we want people to be
educated we don't want a bunch of
ignoramuses running around we want you
know and that that's a good thing
education is a good thing
here's the oxime it's the paradox of it
though if you're stupid in the way you
go about being educated did you hear
that if you're stupid in the way you go
about being educated or the way you
provide education to the society you
don't create a well educated productive
citizenry you create overwhelmed
hopeless people living in their parents
basements who cannot see making $800 a
month $1,300 a month how they can pay
$2,000 a month for student loans that
they can't get out of by bankruptcy
Congress saw fit to loan them the money
but will not let them out due to
bankruptcy I'm not suggesting they
shouldn't be let out but the the paradox
is we tried to create this utopia by
loaning people that shouldn't be loaned
money money an eighteen year old without
a job who's never had a job and has no
collateral should not be loaned money
particularly to get an education and
they have no idea what they're gonna do
with their life it's ridiculous and you
thought this was going to turn out well
it didn't create well-educated
productive people it created overwhelmed
hopeless people living in their parents
basements one out of five males between
25 and 32 in America live in their mom's
basement one fifth of them twenty
percent of the male's I'm not insane men
I said males and this the
is part of the problem right here I
can't get a job in my degree well that's
part two to this part part one is go
smack your congressman silly until they
get rid of the stupid program just keep
smacking him or her repeatedly until
their ears are ringing because this is
ridiculous you're destroying our economy
you're destroying our young people with
this it's out of control and it's wrong
that's part one part two is bother to
tell people your children especially
that success is not a correlated to
education
he said that out loud you can be a
successful guy go to college what yes
children are listening their children
are listening children are listening
don't say that Dave you blaspheme on the
radio yes I do
success is not related to education how
many people do you know they got 150
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and can't get through a job interview
because their relational skills are so
pitiful that they're not marketable they
got six master's degrees and they can't
look you in the eye and shake your hand
they can't walk in the building and
smile and act like they want to be there
other than to be a parasite on the butt
of the company nobody hires people like
this I don't give a rip what your degree
is in you have to have the ability to
move in the marketplace and have
relationships and bring value to people
that are trying to hire you otherwise
you're not going to get a freaking job I
don't care if you got 73 degrees you're
still a [ __ ] and you're not marketable
teach your kids that success is not tied
to education get an education because
being dumb is not a good idea but no
matter how many degrees you have nobody
promised you a rose garden darling you
got to go into the garden clip the buds
you know do the stuff you do whatever
the crap you do to grow roses you got to
do that stuff lost the metaphor
completely you can't this is ridiculous
see if I had a better education I could
have done that but I don't have a degree
in horticulture so shut up ah I don't
have degree in chocolates and pastries
either so shut up
although
if you could get one by eating them now
that would be the way to get that degree
so seriously teach people to study
something that actually is marketable in
the marketplace and that their personal
skills their relational skills are more
of an indicator their ability to
persevere their ability to tell the
truth wear a belt on a job interview
comb your freaking hair and take a bath
seriously you would not believe what
people come in looking like in a job
interview
did you just climb off a stripper pole
sister seriously this is a job interview
what is wrong with you people and you
think your degrees are going to offset
that honestly teach your children this
stuff and you parents you go sign them
up for a hundred thousand dollars and
send them off to some school deeply in
debt
thinking education is going to solve
everything for them you're as dumb as
they are parent and one guy called me up
my 17 year old told me he's going to
this expensive private school I don't
know what I'm gonna do is well there's
your problem Bubba my 17 year old
doesn't tell me anything you got
confused the inmates are running the
asylum I tell them stuff like no stupid
little fool you're not going to that
school you can't afford it and I'm
freaking not paying for it
you're going to this school you're
control freak yeah I my way with my
money and my kids cuz I want what's best
for them hey parents grow a backbone
stand up into this stuff help your
children choose a field of study that
makes sense somebody stand in the middle
of Street and say stop it going 140
thousand dollars in student loan debt
you might want to be a mom someday you
might want to do something different
someday and you won't have choices
because slaves don't have choices a
trillion dollars worth of slaves and 50%
of them are in default I think we can
safely call the student loan program a
failed program people look at what
you're doing think this is the Dave
Ramsey show